hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to off I'm afraid that
we have done bad done bad is what we did
and frankly we're just gonna have to
live with our decisions that we made up
to this point if I'm gonna be very frank
here but instead I'm gonna be the batter
I'm gonna go and purify some more UNMISS
begotten Souls UNMISS begotten Souls and
oh we seem to have reached the smoke
Factory
let's purify it and take away everything
that they have to breathe zone three
I like how each individual zone has his
own theme and essence and people that
need to be driven from their homes and
returned to the swamp of plastic though
from which they came using some weird
form of primordial soup exists that
contains all the evil of this world
there's something written here I'll be
back in a minute
it's a poster full of Sam Marx take it
sure I'm the batter why wouldn't I take
it a one oh hello
it's weird seeing people again I thought
I rid the world of you
hang on see the plastic is beautiful
today apply that all you have to say
you're gonna be beautified next oh hello
I think my stem note can help me here
Marga blurr you can always talk to me
you can display at any time by pressing
the shift key we'll all right then I'll
do just that but not because you told me
to ah that's a gross gurgling sound am I
supposed to be moderately disconcerted
by the fact that something is gurgling
in my ear or am I just gonna I'm just
gonna ignore that okay so there's a
bunch of numbers and they're different
colors but there's only one zero that I
can see so I'm guessing that I need to
hit these buttons in an order and
they're gonna be in this room okay
ah this is gonna be easy so right in
front of me is a one shut up Oh God
when i Frick's it up tonight well hello
you look mind prepared to be blinded
more but first I'm gonna look at you
frigging line Spector aggressive
ectoplasmic incarnation mute Specter
misleading ectoplasmic incarnation
purification recommendation absolute oh
Jesus these guys hit hard and apparently
Omega was just suddenly muted this is
gonna be a bit more interesting here
I'll crap again do anything huh now you
get him Orville you do it you're not
Boursin anybody else in any way I was
doing a lot more damage on the whatever
hell monstrosity 's run the zones that I
weren't at that made sense didn't bonk
thank you I might as well just be
regular attacking these guys so how did
I do wrong what exactly did I Oh was I
just unlucky enough to get a monster
excuse me excuse me oh oh oh I see how
it is oh okay so I did something wrong
maybe I need to go towards the one first
oh so far so good but I have no idea
where I am okay I'll just carry on I'm
supposed to do how am I supposed to know
oh I went one too far you have a crown
on your head
allow me to remove it because you two
are not royalty and you need to be
purified you do not deserve the rule Oh
lookey so seeing little spittoon in Deus
but screw you
let me guess I get sent back don't I yep
I do so I need to make sure that I go a
different direction once I reach that
point but how do I know when that point
was well that's bog oh damn it
well we're gonna be here a while I'm
going to level up a lot and everyone's
going to see how bad I am at games
yes okay so that's the path that I need
to take and I need to take it to the to
and then I need to take it to the three
and then I need to go four five six
seven eight nine
how the hell am I supposed to go to do
that doesn't matters is what is it so
yeah oh yes oh yeah hmm I'm gonna be
level 29 by the time I get out of here
thank you markiplier is too stupid to
figure out anything to your friend
building yell out you goes blue yell
Mookie go down oh hi
I'm not talking to you I'm never I was
supposed to talk to him once more under
the breach offer for and for my friends
we go charging through the denizen we
reach the castle keep and then we all
put on pantyhose and stalking when we
reach our hello he got it by turbulence
and you will avoid the specters quite
easily okay [ __ ] once more unto the
breach my friends V and T into the van
then we'll all go to Bennigan's and have
ourselves a milkshake only if it's good
oh oh I literally have to go back and
heal now after rejuvenate my confidence
points because I'm very competent Oh me
and Cooper Grover judoka Claire
I don't mean to do these things just an
accident because I'm dumb ah go all the
way up oh yes yes yes
what's in here I found it yes
ah I'm hiding nothing I promise
sounds real unsuspicious do you need to
be purified
I can purify you just as easily as I can
cave your head in with this here bad I
have in my hand I've leveled up a lot
through a lot of careless mistakes and
you look like you're in need of an
purification therapy there are no ghosts
under the mattresses good to know do not
forget you to make your bed when you get
up Oh get okey then like I hadn't some
to fortune tickets have been found
not that I need those the batter is more
than capable of healing everybody on the
team who are you there's no need to fear
no one bears you ill will for what I did
to zone 1 and zone 2 you better be
careful you'll be next in this zone I
will see your design okay market lawyers
gonna who are you all are you this is
pictures here here now not bad ghosts
right of course I hear our friends oh
this isn't a serious injury
I'm sure Oh
taste my holy wrath corrupt Souls you
just killed that guy you son of a [ __ ]
I want to smack you personally see I am
doing good for this world
those spectres are bad special home mom
gone forever
Jojo oh I see how you are mimei
salvation be yours children of the devil
people act very strangely around here I
should go look for the judge well you're
awfully talkative this round
aren't you batter he's dead that's all
you have to say about that no doubt he's
dead so those bastard specters really
are bad I'm doing good I'm doing good
work here do not bring the deserted to
bed the deserted to bed did you'd be
dead all right let's play this little
game we got air I should be able to go
straight across but from there I do not
know oh I was not able to man oh hello
are you aware that the patterns made by
the leftovers on your plate mean
something no I was not now shut up your
weirdo okay yup then up here and now I
can go one of two ways I can go counter
box to the over-under or I can go up
here and try to oh sure your meat well
or you will not get any dessert your
lunch break must not exceed two hours be
careful
you're different
what's wrong with you Duane I wanna talk
to you I'm keeping my distance what I do
yo dope dope dope unopen out here nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope no no no okay
I've somewhat changed anatomically
speaking but you have obviously
recognized me at first glance I'm your
friend
judge Zachary No
so my disguise is no match for you keen
in unforgiving eyesight Pablo isn't
really in that form at the moment I'm
going to replace him for some time
anyway
I'll be hunting down obscure clues that
I shall take pleasure in revealing to
you little by little in the most
destructive manner ha ha ha I can
already smell the good times I've been
to the dorms it seems that the people
are here aren't afraid of the specters
shut up not afraid of the ectoplasm
that's very odd indeed I must admit that
I have very few customers in this zone
so I'm not very well acquainted with
their local customs maybe you'd better
go to area 2 they call it the treatment
rooms hmm ok it's simple you just have
to take the underground monorail we
should have a race if you get that first
I'll give you an item for free hey by
the way if only been to the western
dorms
perhaps you should explore the East area
before heading off the area do I will do
that you're never gonna give me a free
item you weird weird weird Oh how could
you even combine with the guy that sells
me my crap
yep ahahahaha the Phantom's aren't evil
you shouldn't be scared right whatever
you say I'm still gonna smash him in the
face with my bat how about that the
chore of cleaning is assigned to you
based on your employment number okie
dokie
righty-ho Lukey de Ludo I believe zone
three is the best place in the whole
world
these guys need a not afraid of spectres
voice well gosh I love the cafeteria
food yes I love it a lot no that's
horrible I'm going back to the other
boys oh why do I even bother if you do
not attack the ghosts they will not
attack you the director said the
spectres are nice it must be true oh I
get another one I did another one Oh
what am I gonna call you Epsilon no way
terrible name I got Orville I got Oliver
I'm gonna call you Oxnard you're Oxnard
I got Orville Oliver in Oxnard yeah who
loves an Oxnard I do I do dream sweet
dreams at night sorry batter I know I'm
not representing you're very serious
personality right here but I got Orville
all of our Oxnard here and they're just
the press I wonder what the quickest way
to get back with whoops oh no I got all
of them I'm gonna see what I can do Oh
Oh increasing allies to
I'm gonna beat the crap out of all you
I'm what I didn't know I did I did
everything in them all
oxnard you're the best Oh
snart you up delightful sorry but oh
okay so I'm guessing that the
underground monorail is marked by the
box named em boom the monorail is free
and accessible to all personnel
sensational isn't it yeah what
everything
lee soo-eun has an engine area to floor
here whoa hello I mini-map you went away
very quickly I didn't get to see what
you were doing you should not make so
little noise when you walk it's abnormal
is that is that saying that I'm a ghost
and I'm flat is the batter respecter
it's the battle Oh too bad mark of blur
I've arrived before you at the same time
it was scripted you had no chance of
success anyway so here's a little
something to help you forget the pains
and sorrows of such a non appealing
defeat ago unless you give me an item
for free anyway I'll leave the area now
to search the area
oh whoops I read that wrong if you find
something suspicious
don't hesitate let me know as soon as
possible
you are so weird I think I hate you I
think I hate you very much yes indeed
okay just gonna talk to you
so that's noon nothing no all right come
back when you have fresh news in also I
can't buy anything from you anymore huh
that I was gonna be oh okay oh my god
you have a mask on you're the cat anyway
you just have the mask on
oh maybe maybe done yeah oh those are
what the days do I've been dumb and I
haven't been aim haven't been doing that
at all okay okay there we go all
equipped up and bedded role should match
my new leveling what am I doing here my
new leveling from all that grinding I
did eyes are block right there
this block keeps you from accessing the
switch funny that's what I thought ooh a
buzzin now flip the switch
Twiggy nod off flip the switch flipping
that off rich yeah I did it I did it I
saw oh I did did I actually solve the
puzzle no way if if I pierce the pipes I
could make it come out but if it escapes
I would never get any of it again you
seem to be losing your mind a little bit
there Marty whoa are you didn't you two
have a mutated baby didn't you to try to
clone himself and it turned out all
wrong hey guys what happened let me take
a look at ya von Gacy ghoul with an
unbridled haircut like resistance
against metal that does not make any
sense
I'm just gonna smack into you old you do
not get hurt very much
Punk Oh your dad you didn't even get the
other hits okay wait a minute
the director said if we work properly
we'll keep getting it all the better one
should work his job wholeheartedly mm ah
I did it I was guessing access to the
treatment rooms authorized thank you
thank you
oh it's another room what do you know
hello impossible to get around this
obstacle Wow really
your real winner there it's such a
pleasure to work everyday I wouldn't
want to be anywhere else I wouldn't want
to be away from my friends I think
there's a problem with the dessert my
portion today wasn't as big as usual is
all you're worried about dessert dessert
oh hello walking around the Christmas
tree - happy holidays I'm a genius
entrance reverb - factory employees only
security tests please enter the past
name wait a minute Vaughn Casey I look
that up I looked at that Vaughn Gacy I
know that oh oh oh oh I don't know if it
was capitalized but Vaughn Casey I just
looked at that ah ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
the sugar no don't touch the sugar shove
shove off specters
get out now oh wow
you you wanna eat our sugar too
oh no oh your need of great purification
oh my goodness what's wrong your hand no
wonder you were able to beat those
specters geez you're so weird
hey let me look at you oh wait no that's
not the right guy yeah I didn't do that
right okay aunt Pam I need to look at
you don't die yet I need to look at you
yep a little cavalry burnt employee a
Vesper on sugar deprivation light
weakness against smoke light and
weakness against a bathroom race that's
for sure I think I'm far no don't do
that
I think I'm far overleveled for these
guys because I went through the other
zones already and gained quite a much
experience no no we must protect the
sugar and they're dead I verified them
no hmm mmm it smells awfully good around
here without a doubt that is due to
these piles of immaculate white and
granular powder it seems to be sugar I
think it is sugar seem so hmm well this
is quite surprising I didn't expect to
find such an ingredient at this pearl in
this place maybe we'll find the answers
to that in area 3 logic obliges us to go
on with the third after the second after
all remember we're in a video game
we've got to do things the constructive
way well go on I'll meet you again when
you're there hurry yeah I don't like you
anymore judge No
by the way I suggest you be careful on
your way back the employers seem to be
feeling a bit under the weather
they even appear to be in a bloody bad
Tim I didn't know your bridge okay no
see you later see you later I guess now
that you merge with Pablo it makes sense
that you have a British accent so what
am I doing with these giant piles of
sugar do I do anything with the sugar I
got a fortune seen I need to kill it
gasps poison look girls boys enough wait
all better now normal red glow normal
red glow on the global Gabba why am I
talking like it's been a long day of
recording I'm preparing oh those guys
look fun no no no no no there's too much
white in my head was I not supposed to
kill you on the feeling I wasn't
supposed to kill you
here we go anyway all must be purified
oh there are no exceptions
I will purify you down to the last so
much have it spilled so much this is art
as a teacher red alert
this is important I don't want to start
a new you'll start a new from a bat
injury to the face oh it's it's only
time okay
come here you I need to talk with you
the Phantom's are nice they didn't
attack the sugar you're lying you're
lying
you're Dedinje you're dying you're dying
I'm like frickin unstoppable with
Orville Oliver in Oxnard on my side why
are you lying is that some grander thing
that I was supposed to understand but he
runs it runs so fast in the pipes they
will tell us the secret of sugar but
it's forbidden by the executive suite
don't care you're all gonna be purified
monk it's some problem everything will
be fine you'll see
no I don't think I will I I don't have
the right to eat too much sugar it's bad
that's bad no no your xsn did I just
said you had nothing to fear from
spectres amaya Spectre amaya Spectre am
i Commander Shepard up in this [ __ ] and
I'm a Spectre I don't know I don't think
I want to know I don't think any of us
want to know what have I done what have
I been I don't know exactly I'm going to
find out I think I'm expected I'm gonna
go to area for oh nevermind then I'm
gonna go to area 3 because that's what I
wanted to go all along whoosh any map ok
bye hello sometimes when I go to sleep
I'm afraid that my legs won't be there
anymore when I wake up that's a weird
thought mmm
Mary oh oh it's snowing or is it raining
sugar from the sky
I think this is where am I going
why am I going up oh hello welven okay
there's a block down there why is that
there I see you I see you over there
tell me your secrets tell me your
secrets or I will purify your soul okay
I'll be on that way another one
you must divulge your secrets to me or I
will be like a monoid sorry buddy we
jump why not Yolo oh my god
game of the mortal fall catch 10 add-ons
before the time runs out so the batter
won't crash with bloody noise be careful
about the phantoms if he does three of
them you lose presenters beginner yeah I
will oh no not oh yes oh yes oh oh I had
that yeah no yeah oh come on come on
grab are they're too far away
whoa no no no no ah I was right there
come on there we go gotta be right on it
you gotta be right on it Punk
not today bunk oh no goes for me what
the hell is going on this is like
kookiest oh yeah this is awesome no no
come on there we go ah no get away
no no no no I said no so no I said No
stop trying to seduce me I know stop
trying to seduce me with your
ghostliness lugosi ectoplasmic goo or
seduce me now I'm too pure
I'm to peer about to be swayed God why
do they keep repairing so far away
give me some easy ones yeah I thought
that was gonna get me right the last Oh
Oh victory victory
ah well I don't know how that helped me
but it did apparently hello [ __ ] for
sure your eyes are looking a little
weird there friend
let's just shove her in the tube there's
already anything - okay cool right these
are the sewers he's putting the sugar in
I'm gonna check downstairs before
jumping in there cuz I'll the battery
just loves oh okay sure
why where did you come from I'm the
batter and I jumped down the chimney ah
what is this place uh-oh another history
lesson I haven't won one of these in a
while
uh-huh you're here in the sugar ovens of
vesper than northern part of it on three
here we burn the courses of the people
who died and thanks to an ingenious sure
system transform the vapor into sugar
the tubes which traverse the factory
walls directed to the treatment rooms
where it is washed it's purified from
the remaining ashes oh I think I get it
hang on I have a thought
then the sugar is distributed to all
employees as a reward for the work they
do every day as the work they do to make
the sugar it's a secret halibut the
Vidale of it wasn't hard elven okay
I saw the fifth element I don't think it
was sugar although she was pretty sweet
new hahaha because without sugar people
could no longer bear reality they would
go right who's responsible for this are
you are you bringing me sugar
no that director is responsible
he's in area 4 okay well then we just
reached an entirely new level of crazy
he's dead it's a pile of dead people
Annie's dead this is an oven lit by
corpses I have work to do right and I
have things to purify so yeah
okey here eat here we go I guess oh
hello thank you you were getting me to
that area I need to go to area four I
think
no you son of a [ __ ] scared me Ivan my
heart like locked up in my chest I'm
here I'm here
welcome our cobbler
oh you're gonna give me a history lesson
great let's hear it ah you're here in
the sugar ovens of Vespa
the northern part of zone 3 I know
that's already been explained to me ah
yes
all the better all the better that
certainly buys us some time
I must purify this zones Guardian ah of
course of course that's what I thought I
have an access card for the monorail
let's read area for to me that
mysterious direct why should I follow I
can't go anywhere else so let's go why
not dear weirdo hi stop fidgeting we're
almost there
I'm gonna jump out I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna jump out attention attention
obstacle detected vehicle is unable to
move forward no it seems that there's a
slight problem
so weren't you about to take a look
outside while I keep watch yes that's
exactly what is going on I'm not going
here hello what are you doing in the
middle of the track you look fun oh hey
that's weird or I'm gonna why are you
crying for help
critic burn employee of Vesper on sugar
deprivation ok
I'm gonna kill you that's what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna kill you because I don't
care
you're not attack
are you is he just calling for help and
I'm gonna kill him like doing what am i
doing
well I'm in a row that's good that's
good he's just calling for help I'm
gonna kill him I gotta kill me okay I'm
sorry about this I'm really sorry I
don't get it we're gonna how do I kill
you I should have gone past the amount
of help that you had okay adversaries
purified
I really feel weird about that one hmm
I'm not going there Phil we're not Alan
no sue what's blocking the bad obstacle
disappeared the monorail is going to
depart please be careful during
departure I feel bad about that one if
you like a lot of bad things happen
there this time I'll proceed we'll meet
up again later take care of yourself no
freaking weirdo you weirdo that's a nice
sound I'm glad I'm hearing then right
now okay so anyway I'm all out of time
for this episode to Brandon actually a
little bit long but thank you all so
much for watching hope you're enjoying
this weird series I feel like I'm doing
bad things so thanks again and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
you